so what about you mentioned
predatory behavior
yeah we talked about sex what about
violence predator and prey dynamics
how uh when was that invented
and uh
poetic and biological ways of putting it
like what how do you describe the
predator-prey relationship is it a
beautiful dance or is it a
violent atrocity
well i guess it's both isn't it i mean
when does it start it starts in bacteria
you see these amazing predators
delivibrio is one that lynne margulis
used to talk about a lot um it's it's
got a kind of a drill piece that drills
through the wall and the membrane of the
bacterium and then it effectively eats
the bacterium from just inside the
periplasmic space and makes copies of
itself that way so that's straight
predation there are predators among
bacteria
so predation in that sorry to interrupt
means
you murder somebody and
use their body as a resource
in some way
yeah but it's not parasitic
in that you need them to be still alive
no no i mean predation is you kill them
really murder parasite is so you kind of
live on them
okay so but it seems the predator is
really popular
so what we see if we go back
560
570 million years
before the cambrian explosion
there is um what's known as the
ediacaran fauna or sometimes they call
vendo bions which is a lovely name
uh and and and it's not obvious that
they're animals at all
uh they're stalked things they often
have fronds that look a lot like leaves
with kind of fractal branching patterns
on them um
and
the thing is they've they're found
sometimes
the geologists can figure out the
environment that they were in and say
this is more than 200 meters deep
because there's no sign of any waves
there's no you know
no storm damage down here this kind of
thing
they were more than 200 meters deep so
they're definitely not photosynthetic
these are animals
um and they're they're filter feeders
and we know things you know sponges and
corals and things are filter feeding
animals they're stuck to the spot uh and
and little bits of carbon that come
their way they filter it out and that's
what they're eating
um so no predation involved in this
beyond stuff just dies anyway and it
feels like a very gentle rather
beautiful rather limited world you might
say
there's not a lot going on there
and
something changes
oxygen definitely changes during this
period other things may have changed as
well but the next thing you really see
in the fossil record is the cambrian
explosion
and what do we see there we're now
seeing animals that we would recognize
they've got eyes they've got claws
they've got shells they're you know
they're plainly killing things or
running away
um and and hiding
and and so we've gone from a a rather
gentle but limited world to a rather
vicious unpleasant
um world that we recognize
um and which leads to
um kind of arms races evolutionary arms
races um which again is something that
when we think about a nuclear arms race
we think jesus we don't want to go there
it's not done anybody any good
in some ways maybe we maybe it does do
good i don't want to make an argument
for nuclear arms but but predation
as a as a mechanism
forces organisms to adapt to change to
be better to escape to to or to kill um
if you need to eat then you've got to
eat and you know a cheetah is not going
to run at that speed unless it's
unless it has to because the the zebra
is capable of escaping so it leads to
to much greater feats of evolution than
would ever have been possible without it
and in the end to a much more beautiful
world
and so
it's not all bad
by any means the the but the thing is
you can't have this if you don't have an
oxygenated planet because if you it's
all in the end it's about how much
energy can you extract from the food you
eat and if you don't have an oxygenated
planet you can get about 10 percent out
not much more than that um and if you've
got an oxygenated planet you can get
about 40 out and that means you can have
instead of having one or two trophy
levels you can have five or six trophies
levels and that means things can eat
things that eat other things and so on
and and you've gone to a level of
ecological complexity which is
completely impossible in the absence of
oxygen
this reminds me of the hunter thompson
quote that for every moment of triumph
for every instance of beauty
many souls must be trampled
i there the history of life on earth
unfortunately is
that of violence
just the trillions and trillions of
multi-cell organisms that were murdered
in the in this struggle it's a sorry
statement but yes it's basically true
and that's somehow
is a catalyst
from an evolutionary perspective for
creativity for creating more and more
complex organisms that are better and
better at survival i mean survival of
the fittest if you just go back to that
old phrase means death of the weakest
now
what's fit what's weak these are terms
that don't have much intrinsic meaning
but the thing is evolution only happens
because of death
one way to die is the the constraints
the scarcity of the resources in the
environment
but that seems to be not nearly as good
of a mechanisms
mechanism for death
than other creatures
roaming about in the environment when i
say environment i mean like the static
environment but then there's the dynamic
environment of
bigger things trying to eat you and use
you for your energy
it forces you to come up with a with a
solution to your specific problem
that you that is inventive and is new
and hasn't been done before and so it
forces i mean literally uh change
literally evolution uh on on on
populations they have to become
different and it's interesting that
humans have channeled that
into more
i mean i guess what humans are doing is
they're inventing
more productive and safe ways of doing
that you know this whole idea of
morality and all those kinds of things
i think they ultimately lead
to competition
versus violence because i think
violence can have a
cold
brutal inefficient aspect to it but if
you channel that into more
controlled competition
in the space of ideas
uh in the space of approaches to life
maybe you can
um
be even more productive than evolution
is because evolution is very wasteful
like the amount of murder required to
really test the good idea yeah
genetically speaking is just a lot yeah
many many many generations morally we
cannot
base society on the way that evolution
works that's that's not mentioned right
but actually in some respects we do
which is to say this is how science
works we have competing hypotheses that
have to get better otherwise they die
it's the way that society works we you
know in in in ancient greece we had we
had the the the athens and sparta and
city states and then we had the
renaissance and and nation states and we
you know universities compete with each
other yes tremendous amounts of
companies competing with each other all
the time it it drives innovation um
and if we want to do it without all the
death that we see in nature then we have
to have some kind of societal level
control that says well hit the some
limits guys and these are what the
limits are going to be and society as a
whole has to say right we want to limit
the amount of death here so you can't do
this and you can't do that and you know
who makes up these rules and how do we
know it's a tough thing but it's
basically trying to find a moral basis
for avoiding the death of evolution and
natural selection and keeping the the
the innovation and the and the richness
of it
i forgot who said it but um
that murder is illegal probably curving
it murder is illegal except when it's
done to the sound of trumpets and at a
large scale
so we still have wars
but we are struggling with this idea
that murder is a bad thing
it's so interesting how we're channeling
the best
of the evolutionary imperative
and trying to um get rid of the stuff
that's not productive
trying to almost accelerate evolution
the same kind of
thing that um
uh makes evolution creative we're trying
to use that i think we naturally do it i
mean i don't think we can help ourselves
do it and you know capitalism capitalism
as a form is is basically about
competition and and differential rewards
but
we society and you know we have a
i keep using this world moral obligation
but you know we we cannot operate as a
society if we go that way it's
interesting that
we've had problems achieving balance so
for example in the in the financial
crash in 2009
do you let banks go to the wall or not
this kind of question in evolution
certainly you let them go to the wall
and and in that sense you don't need the
regulation because they just die
whereas if we
as a society think about what's required
for society as a whole then you don't
necessarily let them go to the wall
in which case you then have to impose
some kind of regulation that the bankers
themselves will in an evolutionary
manner exploit
yeah it's we've been struggling with
this kind of idea of capitalism
the the the cold brutality of capitalism
that seems to create so much
beautiful things in this world
and then the the ideals of communism
that seem to create so much brutal
destruction in history and we struggle
with ideas
of well maybe we didn't do it right how
can we do things better and then the
ideas are the things we're playing with
as opposed to people if a phd student
has a bad idea we don't shoot the phd
student we we just criticize their idea
and i hope they improve you have a very
humane lab yeah yeah i don't know how
you guys do it you know
the way i run things
it's always life and death
you